The Joe Rogan Experience what do you
think about a like big game Hunters
like the people go to Africa
Africa is a very complicated situation
yeah because
Africa
has more Wild game right now than any
time over the last few decades and the
reason why they have that is because
they made it very valuable so these
people set up these large Wild game
camps and they people from all over the
world come there and they pay a lot of
money and they hunt and they can hunt
anything wildebeest giraffes they can't
bring it back with them and they can
they can eat the meat while they're
there and they'll donate the meat to The
Villages which they very much appreciate
my friends have been over there said it
is actually a very nice feeling what
about like lions they don't do that
though they don't eat the Lions no Lions
is just
it's just like to say you hunted a lion
the the thrill of hunting a lion you
know and then there's the conservation
aspect of it they do have to kill a
certain amount of lions so they have a
population control that they do so like
when they remember when Cecil the lion
got killed and everybody freaked out
they shut down lion hunting and then
they had a surplus of lions and then
lions were killing too much Antelope and
Angelus so then they had to send in
Hunters like professional Killers to
kill the Lions do you remember this
movie that Kirk Douglas was in yeah
yes so come to find out that's a true
story yes and they did the thing on the
Lions and wanted lions
uh uh he had a
he had an injury he had hurt his jaw his
tooth or something like a real bad like
a bullet hole no he's like oh like
biting something big and he broke a
tooth and so that's why he was hunting
humans because yeah easier it's like
yeah it's like eating cotton candy as
opposed to that right now the other one
was fine but I guess that was like all
right man you on this special diet I'm
on it with you son
let's go get these [__] well
once you eat us it's probably so easy
yeah if we don't taste absolutely
terrible yeah the lion pear was said to
have killed 135 people boom holy [__]
1898 and tell them why his uh because
one of them had yeah right so his little
lion breath probably stunk it said the
uh Sabo man-eaters the most widely
studied man-eating pantherine cats given
their behavior of hunting humans as a
pair as well as Dental injuries reported
in one of the Lions a car is commonly
attributed to big big cats turning to
humans as prey
and these dudes was weird too because
they didn't have Mane they were both
males oh like that is that what they
look like yeah wow how come they didn't
have Mains yeah so they were equivalent
of a guy with a big butt
yeah
but why didn't they have Mains I don't
know that's so strange yeah these two
dudes was
does it say anything about why they
didn't have manes that's so fascinating
yeah no Maze and and his breath I
thought they all all the males had manes
and these two dudes so they were already
outcasts no manes bad breath yeah they
got nothing they went into a railroad
track and eat some dudes
you know you're spending your whole life
trying to kill a zebra they're fast as
[__] you gotta you gotta sneak up on
them you gotta get them and then you
find these people like oh Jesus yeah you
can't even run I'll stumble over their
own feet they're wearing shoes just take
them out and like oh my God this is so
much easier we can get fat yeah no work
they don't have no run no no wow it's
just like they can't even see at night
yes these are morons and they were all
railroad workers or something like that
yeah you just wait until someone has to
piss yeah
Salvo males look different as well the
most vigorous Serengeti male sport large
Mains while the Savo they have short
thin manes or none at all it's all about
water Patterson says Savo is hotter and
drier than the Serengeti and a male with
a heavy Mane would squander his daily
water allowance by simply panting under
a bush with none despair for patrolling
its territory hunting or finding mates
oh wow that's what is rocking ball heads
that's wild I did not know that so are
there lions like that right now that are
there see if you can find like male
lions out there with no manes
wow
that's interesting I didn't know that
existed